hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
democrats clearing the senate hurdle
moving forward with president biden's
1.9 trillion dollar covet 19 relief
proposal
despite concerns from republicans over
the bill's price tag
former reagan economic advisor art
laffer shares his insight
on what financial assistance is needed
to help struggling americans
and concerns over the relief package's
impact on the country's deficit
president biden signing three executive
orders which will roll back
former president trump's immigration
agenda daniel garza president of the
libre initiative
discusses immigration reform and the
chance of bipartisan cooperation
in congress plus commentary from fox
news contributor
pastor robert jeffress the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to fox foxnewspodcast.com
i'm charles payne i'm martha mccallum
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday february 3rd 2021
i'm dave anthony president biden says we
need his massive new corona financial
aid package
but a famed conservative economist tells
us we don't and our debt's already too
high
when's it going to stop it's not and
it's going to
every little ticky tacky whack on that
debt issue
reduces our potential for growth just
that slight amount
and it will have a huge impact on the
prosperity of american
20 years down the road i'm lisa brady
another batch of executive orders
on immigration could that have a
chilling effect
on capitol hill the problem is um that
america is divided
and congress is divided and biden is
already signaling he's showing no
patience for this uniting thing
and and this could spell trouble and i'm
robert jeffress
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
democrats in congress are advancing that
new covert financial relief bill worth
1.9
trillion dollars we need to think big
and we need to act quickly senate
majority leader chuck schumer
we are not going to dilute to dither
to delay and he's ready to sidestep
republicans using a budget
reconciliation process
that can't be filibustered so it could
pass without a single gop
vote they've chosen a totally
partisan path senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell 10 republican senators
did meet with president biden monday
night pushing their smaller proposal
but the president dismissed that telling
senate democrats it's time to be bold
and
he didn't want to make the same error
they made in 2009 during that financial
crisis
but a prominent conservative economist
disagrees
from the standpoint of the economy i
don't think it's very urgent at all in
fact i think it's a mistake
art laffer advised former president
reagan and received the
presidential medal of freedom in 2019.
now there are parts of the 1.9 trillion
that may make sense
for example those that deal directly
with coronavirus and
getting the vaccines out and getting all
sorts of preparations on the health care
stuff
that stuff makes a lot of sense in the
package like this but the rest of it
doesn't make sense i mean frankly
government spending is taxation i mean
government doesn't create resources it
redistributes resources and
taking 1.9 trillion from one group of
people and giving it to another group of
people
is not a stimulus in fact it will hurt
the economy over the long run
it will increase our debt enormously i
mean
almost by 10 percent as a share of gdp
and as such
it's i think it's a it's a it's a buzz
killer
and it will stop our will not stop but
it will slow down the economic growth
that would have occurred naturally
all right i want to get into the debt a
little bit later but i want to go into
certain parts of the stimulus
the direct payments we've already had a
couple of rounds of those we had two
thousand dollars
in 2020 early and then late in the year
we had the 600
payments and now we have a proposed
another round of fourteen hundred
dollars for most americans
bad idea good idea well you know
obviously these people are hurting
they're hurting very very badly
but what happens when you give them
fourteen hundred dollars they spend it
and then two weeks later they don't have
it and you need to do another round
you know this coronavirus caused damage
throughout the economy except for a
small group of people like professors
and politicians who didn't get hurt at
all but the rest of us did get hurt did
lose income
and these payments you know they just
make it harder
to recover and so therefore i i even
though i feel
great empathy towards the people who
really need the money
it's it's just it's not going to last
and it's not going to create the
prosperity which is the real answer
all right now extra unemployment
initially back last year they were
giving 600
a week extra in the federal government
on top of the benefits people already
received
now it's going to be 400 or 300 or
whatever is going to be the final
product here
extra unemployment do you like that it's
not their fault that they're unemployed
you're giving them extra money above and
beyond
normal unemployment benefits which seems
to me to be just a political
process the people who are paying the
taxes and who
are making the contributions to pay for
that are also hurting so
i wouldn't do that either i'd let the
regular unemployment benefits
continue as they do on the state level
to people who are unemployed
they do need help but to pay people not
to work
doesn't make a lot of sense from the
standpoint of economic growth
i wouldn't do the unemployment benefits
either there is more money
for small business with grants this time
there have been rounds of these ppp
loans that didn't have to be paid back
if you met certain
requirements small businesses everything
everyone always talks about
the backbone of the economy do you think
they still need help well small
businesses
are the backbone of the economy but
small businesses don't
need to be kept i mean what you want to
do with the ppp and all of that is
when you have a solvent company all
right that is operating
fiduciarily correctly they're solvent
they're doing providing a service
they're doing well
and then they get hit by the pandemic
what you want to make sure
is their liquidity needs do not morph
into solvency needs so for those
companies that are going to make it and
we're doing just
fine i think ppp makes sense but for
companies that weren't making it anyway
and we're doing well and we're on the
brink those people don't need to be
bailed out
why we put any money into boeing and
american airlines
is beyond me but we have now small
businesses like restaurants and bars and
cleaners and all that
they are the backbone of the economy but
if one restaurant goes under
believe me when the economy opens up
another restaurant will come and take
its place so what you're doing is you're
not saving restaurants
what you're saving is that specific
restaurant with taxpayers money and
i don't think that's the right way to go
either there is a push
for state local governments to get a lot
of money also from the federal
government they've been hurting
they've been a lot of talk that they
can't necessarily
pay a lot of people who are public
employees or
you know firefighters police all those
kinds of people and they need the
assistance do you think that's possible
do you think that's
no those states not now you're getting
into my turf where i can talk
the states that are really wanting the
money are those that are very poorly run
have high tax rates
are losing people losing jobs losing
businesses and they
want their bad financial management
policies to be with upheld for as long
as they possibly can which is a total
mistake
now we here in tennessee we've run
things very well we still have a surplus
we still are doing well
and the reason we have is because our
state is well run we have no income
tax we have low property taxes we have
no death tax
and people are moving to tennessee
because of our low taxes and because of
our fiscal
soundness i think that states like new
york and new jersey and connecticut and
these other places
that have the highest tax rates in the
nation california
it's not our job to bail out high taxes
and bad management
i would strongly oppose any type of
redistribution of monies to those states
but they're they also have been hit by a
pandemic that was out of their control
too right so was tennessee
and so was florida and so was texas and
so was nevada
but they all handled it pretty well
another thing
that is in this bill would raise the
federal minimum wage to fifteen dollars
an hour
there's been a long debate about the
minimum wage where are you on this
well you know the minimum wage it is is
an artificial way of increasing a salary
or pay of a person
as often as not raising the minimum wage
means the person isn't worth the job and
so they go unemployed
so they get no wage rather than
something below the minimum wage which
is a travesty
because either the poor the minority the
disenfranchised
who really need to be brought into the
economy it's specifically focused on
them the minimum wage
and it rarely provides higher wages that
would have occurred in the marketplace
but the one thing that really bothers me
about the minimum wage is
a 15 minimum wage is very different in
new york city or in
san francisco where everything is high
priced
and it is in kentucky if you put a
minimum wage of fifteen dollars in
kentucky
i would guess that almost half the
people in kentucky
more than half would be earning today
below the minimum wage when we put it be
put out of work
it would have enormous burdens on
different areas of the country
and especially on areas that are not
prospering uh
all that well it would hit the poorest
of americans
the worst on the other side there are
people who say you're lifting the boats
and you're lifting people's wages
and you're making them and they're going
to earn a living wage and then that
helps everybody and they're more than 10
times the number of people who will be
helped by the increased minimum wage
than those will lose their jobs
that's the argument let me just let me
just this is this is a
pr firm's uh statement it is not an
economist statement
i don't know of any economist who thinks
that's true okay
but when you look at this it doesn't do
that let's make if this really did why
not make a minimum wage of a hundred
dollars an hour
i mean come on this is the most
vulnerable segment of the society
and i think what you really want to do
is make damn sure
that they get jobs and then hopefully
with economic growth
you can morph those jobs into very nice
high-paying jobs
but if you require a minimum wage that's
too high
they'll never get that first job i want
you to react to white house domestic
policy
adviser susan rice the other day when
president biden put out his executive
orders related to what's called racial
equity
susan rice said this if we closed racial
gaps
in income and opportunity these same
economists have estimated we could add
five trillion dollars to the u.s economy
over the next five years and add over
six million
new jobs okay what do you think totally
right okay
i mean she's totally right just the
minimum wage won't do that what you need
to have is to enterprise loans where you
have
no income tax up to fifty thousand
dollars a year income for anyone who is
residences in the enterprise zone who
works in the business whose location is
the enterprise zone
no payroll tax you get a review of
building codes regulations restrictions
and
requirements to make it so that they
aren't impaired
then you get rid of the minimum wage
especially for teenagers who haven't had
even a first job
if you did that then we could solve
susan rice's problem and she'd be
completely correct
but a minimum wage and welfare payments
doesn't do that
i want to go back to something that you
had talked about really early in our
discussion
and that is the debt our national debt
is obviously growing because of what's
going on with the trillions of dollars
in financial stimulus we're around
we're close to 28 trillion dollars 28
trillion dollars
is impossible to to to even imagine so
do you know how many zeros are in their
trillion dave
twelve am i right there are twelve
you're right but you have to think don't
you
they won yeah but seeing that's so it's
so
big at some point does it matter i mean
like that whatever
well you know what well it matters it
matters unless you're going to default
and if you're going to default it
doesn't matter then might as well go for
the gold
but from the standpoint of this people
have been
way too concerned about
debt because they overestimated the
damaging impact that would have
they looked at debt to gdp which is the
wrong way of looking at it
what you need to look at is debt service
to gdp
and if you look at it that way debt does
do damage
but it doesn't do nearly as much as the
old line conservatives of the 50s and
60s
said it did okay but it also isn't
costless
you know just because it doesn't kill
you the first hour doesn't mean it
doesn't make you weaker
and it does the higher the debt level is
the slower the growth rates of the
country will be
when's it going to stop it's not
and it's going to every little ticky
tacky whack on that debt issue
reduces our potential for growth just
that slight amount
and it will have a huge impact on the
prosperity of american
20 years down the road lastly the state
of the overall economy as we get
through you know we're in the middle of
the first quarter of 2021.
do you think that you know we had wild
swings of course with this pandemic and
the economy in 2020
where where do you think we're going to
be by the end of this year i am very
optimistic about the short-term growth
prospects of the country
i think once these states remove the
lockdown they'll be the spurt of growth
i think that'll be the probably the
first quarter the second quarter in the
third
quarter of this year and then we start
getting into the long run growth
prospects which
i am not very bullish about given the
types of policies that are being
proposed
art laffer a lot there we thank you so
much
for joining us economist of course
economic policy advisory board under
president reagan
great to talk to you very much thank you
very much dave
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up all the talk about president
biden's many executive orders
is with good reason the president says
but he's defending the signing of three
more
on immigration tuesday evening i'm not
making new law
i'm eliminating bad policy he says most
of the policies he's targeting are
decisions he feels ran
counter to national security one order
creates a task force to help reunify
families separated at the border calling
that a stain on the u.s reputation
another aims to address the root causes
of migration
and he's ordering a full review of
immigration policies
this in addition to rollbacks of the
border wall and the remain in mexico
rule for asylum seekers this about
how america is safer stronger more
prosperous when we have a fair
orderly and humane legal immigration
system
but former acting customs and border
patrol commissioner mark morgan
says taken collectively and coupled with
talk of free health care and amnesty for
illegal immigrants already here
the president's orders amount to an open
border policy with the stroke of a pen
in two weeks
president biden has made our border less
secure our country less safe
and endangered the lives of men and
women on front line protecting our
country
president biden says his actions will
help better manage
the border look some of them make sense
and some of them
may i think have unintended consequences
daniel garza is president of the libre
initiative
a non-profit nonpartisan group he also
served in the interior department
under president george w bush i think
one of the ones that makes sense uh
for example is this um family
unification
um executive order that he wants to
create that would be responsible for
identifying the minor children that were
separated you know from from their
parents or
different guardians i use that term
loosely
and then also update the president on on
the progress of that and then of course
you know solutions on preventing future
separations
i understand there's about 545 children
that remain separated and i think that
that's an important
executive order joe biden i think is
expected to
have a role and then there are of course
others that i think deserve more
deliberation and more thought more
consideration
so it's it's a it's a it's very
interesting and fascinating
you know for for each president to to
give full consideration to these things
but look
i think the thought of all americans is
is that really what we should focus on
is is to rely on on congress you know
our representatives
to make those long-term decisions and
legislate
is there a real chance for bipartisan
cooperation
on immigration in congress though
because every time the issue comes back
around
it seems to be just as controversial as
the last time
and then nothing actually gets passed in
terms of broad
immigration reform yeah you're right i
think the shame of it is that our
immigration system
should really work to harness i think
the entrepreneurial and
an industrious spirit right of people
that are motivated to contribute you
know who want to come to america
and um dictate their own destinies and
achieve the american dream you know
those who want to start businesses you
know take the hard jobs and help
uh build stronger communities um a lot
of them right now are also on the front
line on the soviet
this covid pandemic so and look you know
75
of americans agree immigration is good
and so congress must resolve this
uh we're we're hopeful we're going to be
working with both sides to bring both
sides together so we can reach some kind
of consensus
um look every administration before the
biden administration has failed for some
time now
and i think it has to do with the fact
that um
sometimes they just want to impose their
their version of what immigration reform
is
um look the democrat party does not
define what immigration reform is and
neither does the
republican party they both have to come
together that means you know each side
has to lose a little to gain
much more for the american people and
and so until they're willing to
reconcile their differences
uh and compromise i don't know if we're
going to get to the place we want to be
well and when they can't find common
ground you end up with a situation
like daca like the so-called dreamers
brought here
illegally as children and you know
president trump
challenged president obama's executive
order shielding them from deportation by
setting up the so-called daca program
um and yet you've got both sides of the
island congress expressing support
for the dreamers but that was one of
president trump's arguments is that
that's an example of where congress
should be coming up with a solution
and not the president yeah you know
unfortunately
um senator marco rubio had already
intended to drop real legislation
that would address the dreamers and so
the president
precipitated that legislation with his
own executive order
and look um this i'll give
the president credit on one thing
president obama was that at least he
tried to
arrive at a legislative solution before
of course you know he
he got frustrated and and then took
matter into his own hands
um biden is not even waiting for
legislation he's already dropping
executive orders uh prior to that it's a
different strategy
and it's not a desirable situation to
have the executive
circumvent congress you know the
people's representatives now to be fair
like you had mentioned a lot of these
are reversing
other executive orders that were that
were put into place by a
another president president trump in
this case um
and you know folks like ronald reagan
had 300 executive orders and
george bush 200 and and so on right
everyone used this as a legislative tool
the problem is um that america is
divided and
congress is divided and biden is already
signaling he's showing no patience for
this uniting thing
and and this could spell trouble um
because if you're gonna you know
legislate by
by executive fiat um you're going to
amass more power and you're going to
serve the role of congress
and and there are unintended
consequences to that
one of the policies that the new
president is reversing
that's considered something that maybe
could cause problems
is the asylum policy uh president trump
had asylum seekers waiting
in mexico instead of dispersing
throughout the u.s
and then sometimes not showing up for
their asylum hearings
um you know supporters would argue that
that policy and also
you know funding for the border wall
another issue that ended up in court
slowed the flow of illegal immigration
into the u.s
would you agree are we is this going to
spawn a renewed
crisis it definitely served to
to um hinder uh
unchecked um entry uh
by illegal entry um at the time
look at at the same time i think we need
to be
humanitarian and everybody understands
that what we need is is for this
administration to work with both parties
to pass solutions that are going to add
more
immigration judges who can speed up the
process of cases
and resolve the backlog and of course
speed up in in the way that that also of
course
allows them due process another thing
the byte administration
is doing is this three-part strategy
aimed at addressing what they call
irregular migration
they say they want to help tackle the
instability and other factors that drive
migrants north to mexico up from the
south from further south
and into the united states and to
collaborate better with some of those
other countries
i mean that's something that at least on
some level previous administrations have
done or tried to do do you think that
this is something that's needed is to
really try to ramp up that effort is is
that going to help or are people
you know still just want to go going to
want to get out of honduras in guatemala
and el salvador
yeah and and here we get into what the
push factors are for
a lot of folks in central america and
really it's the low quality of life it's
it's the lack of freedoms it's no job
opportunity lack of educational
opportunity the violence the war
the famine and a lot of you know just
want to reunify with family here in
america
the pool factors that are i think
pulling people towards america is of
course you know the promise of the
american dream
that there's economic opportunity that
there's freedoms freedom of speech
press faith uh our system of democracy
and and
and you know relatively equal justice um
these are all things that that how do
you duplicate these
things um and basically what we need to
do is
is to uh instill uh the kind of
systems and institutions the strength of
these institutions in those countries
and that's gonna take a lot of work
um and this three-part thing that he's
talking about
look you know when i was talking about
unintended consequences
this deportation moratorium uh you know
this is an executive order
uh that has been challenged by my home
state of texas for the possible
violation of you know administrative and
procedures act
uh it's that part where you know the
president has to take due care
to execute the laws passed by congress
and um
again it's the problem of litigation
here uh texas won
because they made the argument that the
you know the
the the administration uh had not proven
why the
moratorium was necessary and it would
the failure to remove aliens
would also encourage additional illegal
entry and that's exactly what
what's happened we've we've already seen
from this time last year
the the the folks who have crossed
illegally double are we at a point
though where we should rethink
our legal immigration policies
i mean it can be complex to come here
legally
on the other hand um you know if
there's always a concern that legal
immigrants are gonna
possibly you know take jobs away from
out of work americans especially during
the pandemic
um but if you would that help if you if
we address
legal immigration make it easier on some
level would that help address
illegal immigration well here's the
thing
um throughout the arc of history
immigrants have been coming in waves
poor immigrants by the way coming to
america
and they have made us stronger because
they've taken those low-skilled jobs
that americans have moved on and up from
and
there then it comes a time when those
immigrants move on and up
out of those jobs you know in
agricultural fields and
towering hot roofs in the back rooms of
restaurants or
hotel rooms you know uh washing dirty
dishes and
humid kitchens you know these kind of of
jobs are taken by immigrants now those
are the low-skilled workers and then we
have the high school workers who
not only are taking um you know the
these job opportunities but they're
creating wealth for other americans
and creating job opportunities the the
the
founder of moderna who is now helping us
with the vaccines
is an immigrant um
and there's millions of those stories
like my parents who came in as farm
workers
and worked the fields and orchards and
then saved their money after 20 30 years
working in the fields
and bought a small business and hired
other americans
you just see it over and over again
where immigrants what they do is not
only take jobs but
and generate wealth but they generate
wealth for other folks
other americans and that has been i
think the legacy of americans
we should have a system that is flexible
that accommodates for immigrants
who come here to work hard to achieve
things to innovate
and keep those out who would exploit
america
we decide who comes in and under what
conditions
and when you have disorder at the border
i think americans get concerned about
that
well president of the libre initiative
daniel garza
thank you so much for your time today
that was an absolute pleasure thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind the biden
administration has decided to abolish
the mexico city policy
the policy was first instituted by then
president ronald reagan
who declared that the u.s government
would no longer give funds for global
aid to international organizations
that promoted or performed abortions for
decades the policy has gone
in and out of enforcement swinging back
and forth depending on who controls the
white house
president biden's long record in
politics
is littered with support for half
measures
and compromises on abortion i'm not sure
whether someone can really be moderate
on abortion
but joe biden tried for decades to
occupy
some kind of mushy middle ground on this
important issue
that is until last year of course
planned parenthood used their deep
pockets
and their outsized influence to keep the
democratic party in lockstep
with their agenda biden folded like a
cheap suit
his campaign embraced an anything goes
abortion on demand
platform after all his talk about unity
during the inauguration
people began to wonder how biden might
deal with this lightning rod issue
when asked about the new
administration's abortion policy
before biden rescinded the mexico city
policy
press secretary jin saki dodged the
question
and instead gave a lame excuse on the
president's behalf
she said quote i will just take the
opportunity to remind
all of you that he is a devout catholic
and somebody who attends church
regularly
anyone with an ounce of discernment can
see through that religious
ruse the christian gospel is not merely
performative
it is transformative biden's sunday-only
religion
is certainly something but it's not
historic christianity
the real gospel of jesus christ
transforms every area of our lives
there is no public private distinction
for a true christian
there is a word for what biden is doing
hypocrisy
president biden's hypocrisy is so
blatant and so egregious
that even his own church won't stand for
it he has been denied communion in the
past by the catholic church
for his refusal to align himself with
the church's pro-life teaching
biden's abortion policy is so brazenly
contradictory to what his own faith
advocates
that every devout catholic would and
should be terrified
but instead of backing down president
biden has doubled down
the mexico city policy rests solely in
his hands
it stays or goes at his sole discretion
and he has once again cast his lot with
the abortionists
all in the righteous sounding name of
global aid
may god have mercy on our country
this is robert jeffress for fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say
alexa play news from fox in fox news
it's the latest when you need it on
demand
from fox news and amazon alexa love fox
news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes